we are a week away from St Patrick's Day
the luckiest day of the year but the St
Patrick's Day activities are starting
early yeah you may want to Shamrock your
way down to Water Street in Henderson
for three days in a sea of green for the
community favorite St Patrick's Day
Festival and the parade there tomorrow
that's where our Brian will is right
there are you checking out some rides
what's going on
yeah top of the morning to you guys here
and of course we are lucky to be joined
by Kathy and Cindy who are help
organizing this event and are going to
tell us a little more about it so let's
start off with what is going on when are
things starting we start tonight at 5
p.m the carnival will start going we
have vendors we have food we have live
music whiskey tasting and a beer garden
sounds like a little bit of something
for everybody and then Kathy's joining
us here she can talk a little about
Saint baldwick's and their help of
fighting Childhood Cancer Kathy hi good
morning yes St baldrick's is our largest
fundraiser for the festival and we will
be tomorrow we will have a booth open
from noon until 8 30 p.m kinds of yard
games head shaving some whiskey bottle
ring toss lots of prizes for young and
old so come on by and donate some money
for this great cause so we have a little
bit of everything for everybody here and
actually we're going to hit it on the
Merry-Go-Round so we're going to try out
this ride get it warmed up for you guys
and uh you know Cindy Kathy what are you
looking forward to this weekend the most
well I hope we have nice weather but
we're looking for a lot of employee
employees residents of Henderson to come
down and just have a great time and
celebrate St Patrick's Day awesome well
we'll check back in with us later we'll
let you know how these rides are and
we'll touch on a little bit more and
show you a little bit more of the
grounds here when we come back we're
going to hit it for now and get on the
Merry-Go-Round we'll check you guys in a
little bit
Brian needs to jump on the Giant rabbits
hold on there he goes oh there we go
Wrangle that rabbit Wrangle it
such a great event and of course such a
great cause they mentioned Saint
Baldrick Sherry and Heather you've done
a lot of work with them in the past and
it's such an important uh charity in the
valley great yeah but they got a parade
they got everything going the parade is
at 10 tomorrow and uh the announcer is
going to have to hang on to their script
because it could literally fly away it
really could put it on a clipboard
everybody put everything on a clipboard
under